(mysterious string music)
- [skekGra] Once we were one.
A single single luminous form.
One body, one will, one mind.
We were perfect unity.
We called ourselves
urSkeks.
- [urGoh] Two thousand trine ago,
eighteen of us left our world
and came to Thra.
(fabric rustle)
(gasp)
- [Brea] They're from another world.
- We newly arrived urSkeks filled mother
Aughra's head with stories
of our adventures
amongst the stars.
She longed to explore the
universe herself
so we gifted mother Aughra
with her orrery
in exchange for the Crystal of Truth.
But there can be no light
- [urGo] without dark.
- [skekGra] We deceived
Aughra and harnessed
the power of the crystal for ourselves.
Then in our arrogance,
our experiments on
the crystal broke us into two.
- [urGo] The Skeksis and Mystics.
- [skekGra] In the shock of division
a skirmish arose.
And the rathful Skeksis broke a shard
from the crystal creating the darkening.
(gasps)
- [Rian] Where's the shard?
- [skekGra] We were
left as two left as two
halves trapped within separate bodies.
(hissing sound)
All we want now is to
return to our true form.
- [urGoh] Where two is one.
The other Mystics went into hiding
and await the day when their destiny
will reveal itself
at last.
- [skekGra] We tried to
convince our fellow Skeksis
that we must be made whole.
That is when they turned on us.
Branded me heretic.
And forced us into hiding.
- [urGoh] We want to be rejoined
now.
Every moment one are two
is too terrible
for one to bear.
- [skekGra] But there is hope!
For we have glimpsed into the future
and seen our fate lies in the hands of
the Gelfling.
- [urGoh] For the Gelfling
are closest to Thra
(distant roar)
- [skekGra] Skeksis will stop at nothing
to preserve their dominion over Thra.
And so,
we forged our knowledge into a blade.
- [urGoh] The Dual Glaive.
(inspiring orchestral music)
- [skekGra] Cast in the deepest fires
of inner sun,
it carries the spirit of Thra
and, when wielded by Gelfling,
holds the power to unite the seven clans
and defeat
the Skeksis.
(crumble sound)
(crackling sound)
- This is the sigil of great power
the Olreal.
- [Rian] I know that symbol.
- [Brea] I saw it in a vision.
- Seven clans,
- [urGoh] Seven fires,
- [skekGra] Joined as one
in the cause of unity
(hopeful music intensifies)
(crackling sound)
- [urGoh] What?
I'm on fire!
Put it out!
- [skekGra] Put it out! Put it out!